accueil à présent bixente mais rien
senti stéphane qui nous a rejoint sur le
plateau bonsoir bonsoir je suis vous
êtes là pour revenir sur les résultats
de la deuxième plus grande
circonscription des yvelines la 9e
circonscription elle qui occupe tout le
nord-est du département et vous allez
nous expliquer pourquoi on parle de
cette circonscription oui c'était
important de revenir sur cette
circonscription justin puisque ici est
passé beaucoup de choses hier tout
d'abord c'est la seule des yvelines où
le rassemblement national s'est qualifié
pour le second tour ça c'est la
véritable information dimanche prochain
le député sortant bruno millièmes du
parti de la majorité présidentielle sera
opposé à laurent morin responsable
départemental du rnc la première fois
qu'un candidat est reine est au second
tour d'une élection législative dans le
département des yvelines où ils écoutent
nous avons réussi au fur et à mesure par
je crois notre sérieux je crois aussi un
travail de terrain un travailleur
relationnel avec les différents acteurs
du territoire a montré que nous pouvions
représenter des candidatures
alternatives sérieuses et je crois que
ce résultat le concrétisent 32 communes
donc sur les 88 de la 9e circonscription
était remporté par laurent maurin
beaucoup de petits villages mais quand
même neuf municipalités de plus de mille
votants à bonnières-sur-seine et
ft-romeu freneuse notamment deux
communes de plus de 4000 habitants il se
place devant le candidat nubes victor
payack donc un résultat plutôt
satisfaisant là on l'a vu pour pour l'or
noir justement dans cette zone qu'en
est-il de nu ps c'est la désillusion
victor bac qui termine troisième et
écoutez bien à seulement 88 voix de
laurent maurin un résultat frustrant
forcément pour le jeune de 21 ans qui
lui coûte sa place au second tour on est
forcément un peu déçu parce que c'est
vrai que jean luc mélenchon sur la 9e
circonscription des yvelines avait fait
un score assez impressionnant notamment
aux mureaux après on l'a vu toute la
journée il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
mobilisation il ya beaucoup
d'abstentions et ça c'était nationale
donc voilà on s'attendait à un petit peu
avoir une perte par rapport au score de
jean luc mélenchon présidentielle ça
fait partie du vieux mais bon on est
quand même content que l'équipe ait sa
rivale troisième comme aux
présidentielles avec jean luc mélenchon
la vague du ps à déferler aux mureaux
40% des suffrages exprimés mais c'est
une donnée d'autant plus frustrante au
final pour victoria que le conte le
disais plus tôt seulement 30% des
habitants se sont rendus aux urnes et
justement pour le second tour le favori
c'est le député sortant bruno milian lui
arrivait en tête il part forcément
favori mais le second tour dépendra
aussi du report des voix vers le
candidat soutenu par emmanuel macron on
peut supposer que certains électeurs
nubes pourrait voter pour lui même
situation pour les républicains qui ont
réuni 10 % des voix avec pauline
vinokourov le faire mais attention
néanmoins au rassemblement national qui
pourra compter sur reconquête qui a fait
5 % sur ce territoire en écoute bruno
myle yens sur ce second tour justement
où deuxième tour bien évidemment je vais
essayer de rassembler tous les
républicains pour faire front contre le
rassemblement national parce que je me
suis battu toute ma vie contre l'extrême
droite et c'est pas aujourd'hui je vais
arrêter et si on est un tant soit peu
républicain on craque on se doit d'aller
voter le 19 et antigua d'aller voter
contre le rassemblement national quoi
qu'il en soit le sivu suspense reste
entier dans une circonscription classé
parmi les mauvais élèves dans le
département en terme de participation à
presque cinq points de la moyenne
départementale qui elle est à 51% et
justement m raphaël mata duvignau pardon
un petit mot sur cette circonscription
est la seule avec le rassemblement
national
oui effectivement c'est un ça fait
partie de la vie à l'exception de la
daisy film maintenant c'est vrai qu'à
quelques dizaines de voix près on aurait
pu avoir un résultat s mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de par austin et ça je
me suis très c'est le résultat tellement
du candidat reconquête qui nie à
résultat quand même assez intéressant
m'intéressant à s'élever finalement on
va la vie nationale que dans ce cas là
ça peut jouer en faveur
il y aurait en toute logique un millième
réélu ça il n'y a aucun a priori
mais c'est intéressant de voir que dans
cette circonscription la faible
participation est plutôt favorables
finalement
l'extrême droite rennes plus de
reconquête
mais a priori a pas de je te montre que
le candidat sortant sera réélu en tout
cas merci beaucoup bixente mayence
insisté ban pour ces informations
journalistes pour tv 78